we were driving just a Toyota or  something and I'm in the back and I I  just got the two New York newspapers  right I was like yeah I just got a joint  bank account they just silence yeah me  and my girl just got a joint bank  account they were like what the [ __ ] did  you just do I'm like we got a joint bank  we're gonna be sharing a bank account  you [ __ ] idiot I'm like what and they  [ __ ] drove me  seven blocks past where they were  supposed to drop me off intentionally  and it was in the ghetto yeah yeah and  they took my papers and threw them out  the window and they made me get out and  it was like mid-winter it was [ __ ]  freezing I don't want to litter so I'm  kind of picking it  [Laughter]  please I'm picking up these papers  [Laughter]